und mein kollege michael engelberg ist
vor dem turnier zwerg in rheda
wiedenbrück michael guten morgen wie ist
die lage aktuell am montagmorgen bei dir
ja guten morgen normen also die lage ist
ehrlich gesagt ruhig also wenn man
wirklich ganz still ist hört man eine
maschine und das ist eine kehrmaschine
die den hof des betriebs reinigt und die
vögel dass es völlig ungewöhnlich
normalerweise wird hier richtig brummen
auf dem parkplatz hier vor uns stehen
bestimmte 30 zugmaschinen die natürlich
alle in deutschland und europa unterwegs
werden um fleisch transporter zu ziehen
allerdings ist er seit donnerstag der
betrieb stillgelegt und die leute sind
in quarantäne
und es wird weiter getestet und die
testungen nimmt unter anderem auch die
bundeswehr vor
die hat der landrat zu hilfe gezogen und
neben mir steht oberstleutnant kurt
herkommt wie ist die bundeswehr hier in
den einsatz eingebunden ist und inlands
einsatz was ja für die bundeswehr nicht
total gewöhnlich ist wie ist es dazu
gekommen und was es genau die aufgabe
ihrer kamera ja in einer ersten phase
hat der landrat eben ein
amtshilfeersuchen an die bundeswehr
gestellten um und um unterstützung mit
soldaten gebeten vor allen dingen bei
der testung auf dem werksgelände
turniers das ist geschehen diese testung
ist am wochenende abgeschlossen worden
das werk ist ja seit samstag 23 uhr in
gänze geschlossen danach hat es eben
einen neuen amtshilfe antrag gegeben
seitens des kreises mit der bitte
weitere soldaten zur verfügung zu
stellen um eben bei den mobilen abstrich
teams die jetzt sozusagen von haus zu
haus gehen zu unterstützen
nicht nur die bundeswehr ist ja im
einsatz auch das drk also ganz ganz
viele hilfsorganisationen versuchen hier
dem landrat und dem kreis gütersloh
unter die arme zu greifen
die bundeswehr ist jetzt ungefähr noch
mit knapp über 30 personen hier im
einsatz
und dennoch ist es wie gesagt nicht
alltäglich dass die bundeswehr im inland
hilft allerdings ist die bundeswehr
nicht nur bei den abstrichen im einsatz
sondern sie unterstützt auch bei der
lebensmittel vergabe herr oberstleutnant
wie geht das genau vonstatten
also das muss ich leider dementieren es
gibt keine keinen einsatz zur
unterstützung bei der lebensmittel
vergabe das machen die zivilen
hilfsorganisationen und nach meinem
kenntnisstand sind sie auch wirklich
breit und gut aufgestellt um die aufgabe
alleine stemmen zu können
und es geht allerdings auch weiter der
landkreis hat gestern der landrat hat
gestern gesagt dass jetzt die
möglichkeit der freiwilligen testern
beginnt das hat herr tennis dann so
beantwortet das ja auch die freiwilligen
tests übernehmen will
der oberstleutnant hat gerade gesagt sie
sind nicht in der lebensmittel vergabe
tätig allerdings in sachen abstrichen
jetzt ist die testung hier auf dem
werksgelände zu ende nichts desto trotz
muss ja auch in sieben bis zehn tagen
weiter getestet werden also die leute
die unter quarantäne stehen müssen ja
weiter getestet werden
der oberstleutnant gibt es da schon
irgendwelche pläne wie das funktionieren
soll also das obliegt natürlich der
planung des krisenstabes
fakt ist und das wissen wir dass geben
die regeln her dass nach sieben bis zehn
tagen erneut getestet werden muss und
das heißt eben auch alle arbeiter alles
knapp 7000 arbeiter müssen erneut
getestet werden
und da arbeitet man im krisenstab gerade
daran dies zu organisieren
inwieweit dann eben eine unterstützung
durch bundeswehr gewünscht wird das
bleibt abzuwarten fakt ist wir stehen
mit genügend soldatinnen und soldaten
zur verfügung er sich dank herr
oberstleutnant ihr habt gehört die
bundeswehr steht weiterhin zur verfügung
heute wird es noch weitere ergebnisse
von ausstehenden test geben und wir
werden uns
hilden band sich hier signifikant was
ändert